there is a perception that landlords are
flush with cash that they've got loads
of money and then it doesn't really
matter if someone doesn't pay rent I
mean you're described as a millionaire
landlord I mean is that accurate I'd be
embarrassed to be a millionaire I'm a a
multi-millionaire and I make over a
million pounds a month if I was a
millionaire I'd be very embarrassed many
millions suppose with respect Samuel I
suppose the argument might be that you
probably could afford for somebody to
maybe not pay rent that's a terrible
argument that's a horrible argument I
mean you could say oh well Asda can
afford it Asda can afford for people to
go in and steal bread but we wouldn't
say that because it's immoral you should
pay for the service that you have it's
irrelevant how rich I am